what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with maestro war and packs by
peter david now it's been a while since
we covered this because we wait for them
to finish before we cover them all those
you guys who aren't familiar with this
maestro is basically a version of the
incredible hulk from a story called
future imperfect which has been really
really popular among incredible hulk
fans for years the one thing we didn't
know is how the maestro rose to power
this gives us that right this tells us
how it is that maestro hulk became
maestro hulk so make sure you guys check
the playlist it'll get you caught up
with the first video that we did uh and
so this one is going to give us really
like one of the most epic battles ever
which is like maestro vs doctor doom uh
and honestly i really think it's like
world war maestro like world breaker
maestro versus uh versus doctor doom so
here's the thing about this right out in
hartford connecticut one of the things
that happens is this is kind of one of
the last holdouts of human civilization
right that they call themselves the
stalkers now as a little bit of a catch
up here and what kind of you know inject
these in the story as we as we sort of
go through that the world had basically
succumbed to like nuclear war right and
the maestro hulk had emerged as
essentially the only guy who really
survived it only really seemed to be
aware of what was going on i mean there
were a few survivors here and there like
advanced idea mechanics uh modoc people
like that and we'll actually find out
there were a few more survivors but not
everyone was destroyed but the the fact
remains that when it comes to just
average humans they largely took refuge
in like major cities as you would expect
and then started forming different
societies and things along those lines
hercules had been the one to basically
form dystopia uh where he ruled as the
leader of that place and then maestro
toppled him and then ultimately took
over and so what this does is it
initially has maestro showing up in
connecticut and then basically
eradicating the last of these human
holdouts now one of the things to know
is it's not done arbitrarily instead
what the maestro had done is he had
actually sent an emissary to these
people to invite them to join dystopia
now the reality is the maestro's
invitation was join me or die that's
basically what it was and they sent his
emissaries head back on a pike and so
maestro just took the response for what
it was showed up here and killed every
single person that was fighting it was
basically all the adults who died
following that the kids turn on the
maestro and then basically say like like
go to hell right like they intend to
basically fight against him so at that
point he sticks his forces on the kids
and then takes all of them out and so
again the ruthlessness of maestro here
right this guy is just hardcore the
crazy thing though is that there is
basically somebody surveying hartford
connecticut watching this whole thing go
down and comes to the realization that
this is something that could prove to be
exceedingly difficult now at that point
we switch over to washington dc now the
maestro set its sights on dc because as
the capital of the united states it
would be most likely the most popular
city to go to just because of the fact
that there are a lot of places that are
within traveling distance of washington
dc and it's just a well-known place
right i mean it'd be different if
somebody said like meet me in
schenectady new york no one's gonna meet
there
no one really even knows where that is
at least i don't know where it is i just
know that it's a place that exists
because the name's weird but with the
exception of that most people would
choose washington dc as like a place to
arrive at now aaron stack is basically
machine man and it's kind of funny that
he's here because historically speaking
machine man was a really really big deal
back in like the 60s and 70s he hasn't
been a big deal for like 40 years in
marvel comics he hasn't been relevant in
decades but basically aaron stack is
quite literally a machine right he's a
robot designed to look like a person but
he also follows logic and reason now as
far as washington dc goes again because
this is one of the last remaining human
holdouts they have all kinds of
resources at their disposal right
they've got food they've got all kinds
of things weapons arms and arms and so
on and so forth and so it's a very
tactical place for the maestro to
essentially conquer and so what he ends
up doing is basically sending his
emissary right sending his minister to
uh to washington dc basically telling
aaron stack the exact same thing they
told the people in hartford connecticut
that in the end the maestro is going to
rule everything either they can be
subjugated peacefully or they can be
destroyed violently but only one of
those two things is going to happen and
in the end of course as a free people
they basically rebel right they're just
like no the maestro is not going to take
over us that's never going to happen and
so because of the fact because of that
particular fact when the maestro arrives
on the scene and basically finds out
that his invitation has essentially been
rebuked aaron basically initiates
something called operation egress which
in essence gets everybody out of there
they basically all start evacuating but
in the midst of all this the maestro
shows up and then immediately starts
attacking aaron stack now while that
goes on what we actually end up getting
is basically delphi who is essentially
observing all these things that are
happening and what ends up going on is
because of the fact that she had seen a
kind of vision she basically ends up
meeting with adelon now for those of you
guys who don't know who this is this is
the pantheon now the pantheon were were
really friends and allies of the
incredible hulk at one point in time
specifically during the peter david run
so it makes sense that he would bring
them back they have not been relevant in
years so if you haven't heard of them
it's not a huge deal right it's not a
big deal at all just know that they are
all basically descendants of agamemnon
who is half as guardian and half human
very similar to thor but thor is like
half mother earth right he's like cosmic
deity or whatever you know however you
want to refer to it but in essence they
are by all standards of measurement
essentially long like long lived they're
not technically immortal but they can
live for an exceedingly long amount of
time so they're very similar to the
externals for those of you guys who are
familiar to mutants uh but ultimately
they say that like delphi basically had
a vision now delphi's powers are very
ambiguous you know to a degree in the
sense that she can have like
premonitions but it's very difficult to
determine whether or not they are
accurate premonitions the only way to
know is to just wait and see what
happens in a lot of ways or to act or
something like that but they are allies
of the hulk and this is the reason why
they choose not to act or at least
they're instructed not to act by their
leader right they're literally told stay
here do not do anything we are not going
to intervene we're basically just going
to stay put right banner was at one time
a friend he stays away we stay away we
have no reason to get involved here and
so following that of course the fight
between aaron stack and maestro it is
pretty interesting aaron stack is able
to hold his own to a degree not really
in any measurable way right i mean he's
able to like you know attack the attack
the maestro and kind of overpower the
maestro or take him by surprise from
time to time but at the end of the day
this battle was a foregone conclusion
right there was no way that aaron's
stack was actually going to win and even
the maestro says that like he rips his
head off of his body and he's like what
did you think was gonna happen did you
somehow think that you were going to
defeat me that you were actually going
to beat me like i'm the hulk right like
you are a robotic man you know that you
literally bring nothing to the table
outside of like the ability to grow
still side of your legs shoot energy
beams from your eyes and punch kind of
hard a little bit i guess but like you
can't really do much at all and so
ultimately aaron stack reveals the whole
thing was a ruse that the body that the
maestro is fighting is actually a
duplicate and that aaron stack himself
the actual iron stack is flying the
people of washington dc of this area
basically to like to a new safe haven
right a place that maestro seemingly
doesn't know anything about on top of
that there is a bomb in the body of
aaron's stack so that if his body is
catastrophically damaged it'll detonate
that goes all the way back right that's
old school stuff it's been that way been
a part of his character ever since he
was initially introduced to make sure he
doesn't fall into the wrong hands but at
the end of the day of course the
explosion goes off my show's not hurt
tells everybody you know don't tell
anyone this happened that kind of a
thing but ultimately the pantheon are
met by the arrival of doctor doom and so
once doctor doom basically gets into the
scene which is kind of funny because
initially they they reject him right
they're just like whatever it's doctor
doom who cares he actually uses his time
platform his ability to manipulate time
to basically find a way into the uh into
the the pantheon headquarters now he
it's not really that he time travels so
much as in marvel comics the ability to
manipulate time is time and space so if
you can time travel you can teleport so
that's the reason why dr doom's time
platform basically serves as both a
teleportation device and a time travel
device because the two are essentially
one of the same but as he gets in there
and as he starts talking to the pantheon
one of the things he says is that in the
end the maestro is going to try to rule
the world right knowing the incredible
hulk as he knows him and with a pantheon
knowing him as they know him that in the
end they all universally agree the
maestro is not going to stop until he
basically has every single human being
on the face of the earth under his
control right until dystopia is the only
place where human beings reside on earth
and so what what dr doom basically does
is say like we need to concoct a plan we
basically need to develop a plan in
order to destroy maestro hulk now one
thing i do want to point out here is
that dr doom is written kind of finicky
in this story uh it's not the way you
normally see him i mean you do have kind
of like the pompous arrogance to a
degree but that's kind of the baseline
doctor doom there really really really
isn't a lot of character death when it
comes to his character he's kind of
basic here but beyond that like it's
just kind of doctor doom here for the
sake of just being like doom survived
and him and maestro were gonna fight
right and that's basically kind of it
but in the end maestro was basically
informed by his minister that uh the
pantheon is or at least seems to be uh
still alive and well right still seems
to to exist out there and in fact
they've actually shown up on the
doorstep of maestro basically as
visitors and when when the minister
tells them like they're the pantheon
maestro's like oh i know them yeah like
they're friends you know and so
ultimately as soon as maestro shows up
ajax starts attacking him now one thing
i want to specify this is not ajax of
the eternals this is they're not the
same person ajax are the eternals it's
interesting he's got character depth
this guy ajax is an idiot like he really
is just a [ __ ] like quite literally
he's just a giant buffoon he can punch
really hard he's really really capable
no one knows how he got his powers but
he's basically just a guy who's there
and so once maestro kind of calms things
down and starts talking to him because
ajax is a [ __ ] and basically starts
speaking in broken english the
simplicity of him recognizes the hulk
and then everything kind of chills and
so at that point what the pantheon
basically reveal is that a member of
their group a guy named prometheus had
basically been killed by advanced idea
mechanics and building on the idea of
maestro in the sense that he is still to
a degree the incredible hulk they knew
he's just they're all basically kind of
like we're looking for revenge we're
looking for a way to get back in
advanced idea mechanics who basically
killed prometheus and so ultimately my
show's like sure i mean i can help you
guys right you guys are friends you guys
are teammates everything's cool but the
question is asked by maestro of atlanta
how was it that prometheus died and
because she dodges the question it's
immediately suspicious because as a very
tight-knit group if she really was
hell-bent on revenge she would tell a
story if for no other reason than it
would basically expand on the maestro's
motivation to make the make advanced
idea mechanics suffer the fact that
she's dodging it indicates that there is
no actual reason and that's when he asks
ajax how did prometheus die and
ultimately the response of ajax is i
mean he was sick right like it was
really really sad and maestro was like
so nobody killed him and he's like no
why and that's when he realizes it's a
ruse that he's basically being duped by
uh by the the pantheon which in turn
knocks him out right they use like just
the super high powered gas right they're
wearing nose plugs and stuff you know
and so ultimately they they're able to
to stay awake during the whole ordeal
and that my show passes out now when
that happens maestro basically ends up
falling unconscious and then the idea of
the pantheon is to use the powers of
paris one of their own who is actually a
telepath on the maestro in order to
basically subdue him to force him to
revert back into his banner form which
is what they were expecting to happen
but didn't actually happen and then
basically kill him that way and so what
ends up happening is that once uh paris
uses his powers on maestro that
basically he just kind of starts
creating these illusions right creating
these kinds of things where maestro kind
of lets his guard down to a degree but
at the same time it's also manipulating
him and so my show realizes pretty fast
what's going on here right where he's
just like no no no right this is
obviously an illusion right this is this
is the base of the mount right this
place that i'm in this is the original
home base of the pantheon it's been
destroyed since forever so right off the
bat he's basically told by paris none of
this is real but in order to begin the
process of conditioning maestro and
basically messing with his mind that he
ends up presenting him with video images
of his father being abusive towards him
punching him and in fact his father
actually attacking his wife attacking
the mother of a banner the mother of
maestro the woman named rebecca and so
in this moment maestro basically freaks
out and then attacks paris and actually
starts choking him because of what's
going on in terms of his mind his
physical body reacts the same way the
connection's locked in paris can't
escape and maestro snaps his neck and
then following that maestro escapes and
then immediately starts attacking
everybody right like just just attacking
the entirety of the pantheon and is
basically able to overcome them now the
significance of this is pretty huge
because you are talking about a
ridiculously powerful team the pantheon
is enough to give the avengers a run for
their money and depending on the
circumstance right depending on who all
is on that avengers team they can
overcome them the pantheon is pretty
tough like they're very very capable
we're talking about some pretty
significant heavy hitters but my show
goes through and kills every single one
of them but in the middle of all this
suddenly his mother appears and that is
enough to basically distract maestro and
in that moment that actually leads to
him reverting back into his human form
because he sees his mom she's like what
have they done to you right what
happened to you giving him that very
very human and very touching moment is
like the one vulnerability that maestro
has and when that happens rebecca shoots
him in the chest and then he just gets
loaded up with bullets only for us to
find out yet again the whole thing is a
trick that paris had basically used his
powers of telepathy to force maestro
into believing that he had actually
killed harris and that maestro was
actually killing everybody there and so
with him essentially dead and seemingly
out of commission dr doom makes his move
he essentially conquers dystopia and
then maestro is buried in an alloy
called uranium right the toughest metal
that they have it's not the toughest
metal in the world remember adamantium
is not easy to produce it's a
ridiculously difficult thing to create
and in fact it's almost impossible to
get your hands on on the right materials
in order to create adamantium the best
they have is uranium but seemingly it's
enough to hold uh the maestro in place
right enough to basically keep uh keep
him contained keep him locked in so he
can never escape but as he begins the
process of passing on he ends up meeting
with leonard sampson right doc sampson
who is a lot of you guys who are fans of
the incredible hulk know for years was
basically the incredible hulk's
therapist and even a member of the hulk
family and in fact he was actually part
of the more more recent uh al ewing
immortal hulk run but essentially it's
kind of like the devil on one side the
angel on the other that where leonard
samson is banner's voice of reason where
he's basically saying like the pantheon
is trying to kill you yet again like
they did before uh they're encasing you
in in uranium they figure that it can
smother you and when it hardens it'll
encase you and and maestro asks the
question can i stop them and the
response of
of doc sampson is you could but the
question is do you really want to do you
really want to live maestro like do you
really want to continue living your life
or are you tired of living at that point
the maestro persona steps in and the
maestro persona literally just kind of
starts tearing into uh into into banner
he kills doc sampson right that persona
right he kills that personality that
kind of angel uh on the shoulder of
banner and then starts tormenting banner
and it's just like you're weak right
like you should know by now i'm the only
friend you have every person out there
who ever tried to quote unquote help you
betty ross rick jones the avengers all
of them right they've all been trying to
weaken you because they're afraid of you
and when banner says like why would they
be afraid of me the response of maestro
is because of what you can be right when
you when you release me trust in me put
all the responsibility in my hands
because of what you're capable of
everyone is afraid of you right they
think they have you show them bruce show
them who's in charge show them who the
strongest one is and that is when bruce
totally relinquishes control of himself
over to the maestro and when maestro
emerges he's twice the size he's bigger
than he was before and stronger than he
was before he's increased in his
capabilities at that point that's when
he actually starts killing the pantheon
or at least attacking the pantheon now
for the most part he is able to
basically kill a couple of them or at
least he's able to kill atlanta their
leader and then in turn it's kind of a
last-ditch effort you ultimately end up
having the pantheon launching their
missiles right launching the missiles
that are available to them like they
have multiple missiles they fired them
all off the first set of missiles is
fired off to advanced idea mechanics
partially because of the fact that in
the face of the fact of the world
basically come to an end advanced idea
mechanics and even the pantheon
themselves they could have done
something to stop it but they didn't
right they just sat by and let it happen
the other reason is because it's
advanced idea mechanics right just
wiping them off the face of the map the
second set of missiles that are launched
when maestro asks like where's the
second set coming the response to the
pantheon is i suggest you leave like if
i would leave if i were you and so
ultimately advanced idea mechanics
underground base is totally eradicated
everybody there is killed the pantheon
themselves are physically destroyed when
the bomb goes off there and in the end
maestro is the last man standing and so
following this he shows back up on the
doorstep of dystopia going after doctor
doom only for us to find out the two of
them had actually been working together
that the whole idea of doctor doom
basically enlisting the aid of the
pantheon was to bring the pantheon to uh
to maestro so the maestro could destroy
the pantheon because he knew it was only
a matter of time because of pantheon
were basically good guys that while they
were they were hands off in the moment
it was only a matter of time before they
made a move against the maestro and
because of how capable they were and
because of the various tools arms and
armament they had at their disposal they
would have been able to organize a
pretty capable resistance against the
maestro that would have gone on for a
pretty lengthy amount of time and had it
gone on long enough and if there was
enough of a an act of desperation they
could have potentially destroyed maestro
and so doctor doom and maestro worked
together in order to destroy the
pantheon and that's when doom is like
okay like now that this is done uh we
can basically both rule our own
individual kingdoms right like we can
rule the world together uh by uniting
our forces and that's when meister
reveals he basically poisoned doctor
doom right the doctor doom is just he's
not a part of the picture anymore now
before you guys start freaking out
because i know a lot of you guys who are
looking for a reason to be angry you
guys are going to be like that's
ridiculous okay that's obviously not
what happens right peter david is a
experienced writer he's not gonna have
doctor doom killed by poison and in fact
dr doom even says that right he's like
yeah i saw this coming man like do you
really think you can kill me with poison
you really think you can poison dr doom
come on man like you gotta try harder
than that he's like i took an antitoxin
before i ever swallowed a single bite
right at the end of the day maestro
you're a simpleton i'm dr doom i'm the
smartest man in the world right now
you're just a guy who's really strong
but you are nowhere near my level i saw
your moves coming from eons away now
this is where things get really really
interesting because while doctor doom is
exceedingly capable dr doom is also
exceedingly arrogant and so all he needs
is one moment where he believes he has
the upper hand and his argument is the
battle is over right like i've basically
won and so this fight goes on for a
pretty good amount of time and happens
all over the place doctor doom throws
seemingly everything he has at the
maestro literally like the lightning of
a thousand a thousand thunderstorms just
all come pouring onto maestro and it's
not enough to stop him but doctor doom
also knows the key to defeating the
maestro is to try to wear him down but
you can't just overwhelm him with brute
force immediately because he'll continue
to get angrier and angrier and as that
happens he'll get stronger and stronger
and so stretching the battle on wearing
away chipping away right making him or
at least forcing him to make mistakes
that kind of a thing and that's one of
the things that he says what he says
like there's strategy then there's
knowing your opponent's weaknesses and
so trying to exploit those weaknesses
that's the name that's the name of the
game for doctor doom and so one of the
things that happens is that maestro
because of the fact that he has the
intelligence of banner with the strength
of the incredible hulk and is
effectively immortal that he also uses
that to his advantage and depending on
who you're talking to arguably in terms
of like combat strategy some will say
banner is more intelligent than doctor
doom when it comes to that because dr
doom's knowledge is largely in like
alchemy magic sorcery whatever you want
to call it right and then just general
intelligence but he's not really a a
fine-tuned tactician he knows how to
fight and he knows how to use situations
to his advantage in order to try to come
out on top but against someone like
banner who's been in fight after fight
after fight especially fighting against
someone like gender general thunderbolt
ross who is a master of battle strategy
you learn a lot along the way and that's
one of the things that happens here is
he says okay so i i know that for a fact
i can't beat you the way that you are
like i know that with your armor and all
that kind of stuff i cannot overpower
you because your armor is just far too
durable in comparison to my ability to
punch and so on and so forth and so what
he does is he lulls him into a false
sense of security he plays possum right
he lures dr doom in and then when that
happens he activates an electromagnetic
system in the alchemax building and when
that happens it strips doctor doom of
all of his armor like literally the
magnets just pull the armor off of him
and when that happens it's just doctor
doom in his human form at that point the
fight's over right the fight's done like
literally maestro just starts pummeling
the sky and dr doom escaped by the skin
of his teeth by basically teleporting
away by essentially disappearing we
don't know exactly where he went to the
only thing that's really said here is
that if doctor doom decides to reappear
that this is going to lead to a future
that is completely and totally imperfect
now the reason why this matters and is
something that i wanted to wait until
now to basically explain is that where
we would look at this and think that
because it's dr doom who is basically
able to time travel that is presumably
the doctor doom from like the main
marvel universe something like that
because that version of dr doom has
encountered maestro before what's
actually going on here is this is dr
doom from the future imperfect universe
the caveat here is that when the world
started to end doctor doom time traveled
he basically jumped forward to what's
going on right now and that's how
everything is unfolding that's why he's
here now in terms of where he's gone in
the time stream we don't fully know
presumably he's gone back to his own
time from before everything came to an
end right before the world was ravaged
by nuclear and biological war but
whatever the circumstance is doctor doom
does appear in hulk the future imperfect
one shot as well as the main future
imperfect story itself so it's not like
we've seen the last of him this just
kind of continues on or at least from
here this is the first time the two of
them met and the presumption is that
this basically goes directly into when
dr doom returned during the main future
imperfect story or at least during the
future imperfect universe line of
stories but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace